foreign
Pennsylvania and talk to the Great and
Powerful Renee what's up Renee
Hi how are you partying how are you
I'm great that's so good what's up
um I'm currently in a relationship and
we have a daughter and
there are some things that are said in
front of her that I'm not like a fan of
during like arguments
so I'm not sure if it's like better for
her for us to be together or not
I don't even know what's being said but
I want to challenge the whole premise
okay
okay she cannot be the reason you leave
your husband or don't leave your husband
she can't carry that kind of weight
right you have to choose am I with a man
who is abusive and childish and let's
take her out of the equation
almost zero percent chance that he's
perfect in every other way and your
relationship is humming along except for
he says impropriate things in front of
your daughter Fair
great so back out and like be honest are
you out of this relationship are you
done
uh sometimes I feel that
way tell me about that
really well for a while and we
communicate really well and then like
all of a sudden like something happens
and it's um like a big argument that
kind of lasts for days and at that point
I'm kind of like
it's hard for me to like trust again
that that's not going to continue to
happen of course because it keeps it
keeps continuing right yeah that keeps
happening who who is the adult who has
the adult body but acts like a child and
keeps an argument going on for days
as that's that's a power move that's not
let's solve this problem or you really
hurt my feelings that's a power move
that's a way to run a household by
keeping a fight going on and on and on
is that you that does that or is that
him
um I feel like it's him would he tell me
on the phone that it's you
yes
so what is it that he's doing
a lot of like kind of insults and really
like harsh like words that are kind of
coming to me and at that point I kind of
like everything's all kind of let's just
get right to the reality like it kind of
is mean and kind of is the greatest ever
what does he say
um he'll say that I'm stupid and that
there's other there's other like curse
words that are being used
and things in reference to me so as an
adult
I choose to not be in a conversation or
relationship with people that angrily
swear at me on a regular basis
right I choose that
why do you think so little of yourself
that you haven't made that choice
um because that's a child
like that's a that's a very childish
thing to do
yeah
just swear and curse at your wife when
you're mad that's just that's what kids
do man
yeah
do you do it back
no I usually like I kind of shut down
and I'll try to walk away from the
situation if that's happening because I
mean I don't really want to deal with
that and I don't feel like that's gonna
produce a positive conversation good for
you
and then when you re-establish control
in your relationship by walking away and
choosing dignity over just getting
berated
he chooses to sulk and hmm and just
carry it on for days and weeks on end
yeah he does not like the walking away
have you ever told him with a smile on
your face
if you would stop
swearing at me and cussing at me and
telling me that was stupid I wouldn't
walk away
actually you know what that gives him
back I want to flip that around I said
that wrong
I think the best way to say it is no I'm
always I always have autonomy
and so I choose to not be around people
who swear and curse at me so if you
swear and curse at me and throw a temper
tantrum like a child
you are choosing for me to go away and I
get the message loud and clear
yeah and I I mean this past week I kind
of because we had like a big fight last
week like that and I kind of
set that boundary where I was like if
that's happening like I'm not going to
be a part of it it's not like acceptable
I can't really continue in a
relationship where that's going to
happen all right so you practice you you
to use your words you kind of put down a
boundary then what happened is he safe
oh no no no no I didn't want that or
he'd say yeah that's right
um like why are you calling do you think
this thing's over
yeah it's hard for me to like kind of
let them go so I feel like I hold on to
some like anger and hurt from those
types of situations you should hold on
to anger and hurt it's ugly it's hard
a guy stood before you and God and your
friends and said I'm all in on you and I
will I will commit to service to you for
the rest of our marriage and you said
the same to him
you know follow that up with you stupid
fill in the blank
yeah
even when you're mad even when you're
just incredibly angry
you don't talk like that
right to me like I know if I'm kind of
getting to a point where I'm angry and I
can kind of pause on that and like come
back to it later and he tends to be very
like explosive yeah
are you safe otherwise
does he punch the wall or throw things
at you
no
do you push him so far and poke and prod
and prod and poke and do things you know
you're gonna set him off
I don't think so
what would he say
um he says that sometimes that I like
uh Panic or
um
get emotional too easily and that's so
stupid he doesn't get to say that that's
dumb
that's just that's gaslighting 101.
yeah and I scream and yell and call
somebody stupid you stupid blankety
blank blank blank blanker and then you
start crying and it's like oh my gosh
you're so emotional
it's so stupid that's yeah that's what
happens it sounds like we'll just stop
crying just talk normal
it's hard to do that after everything
that was just said yeah
I can't be the person that says you're
good you're free to go
and your daughter can't be either
right and I know that
leaving somebody with a young child
creates a Cascade of challenging
situations
yeah but that little girl as you
probably rightfully know is getting a
ringside seat she is downloading into
her nervous system this is what Love and
Marriage looks like and this is how a
woman is to be treated by a man
right and that's like the part that
makes me feel like guilty the part that
should make you feel guilty is the part
that loves and cares for Renee
deserves more
because there's a little girl inside of
you going is this what we're worth
and so it like all that like Kumbaya
stuff here's the deal if I'm you I would
let my husband know not in kinda terms
I've made a an appointment next whatever
for us to go see a marriage counselor or
one of those two-day we're going to
figure out at the end of this two-day
Retreat Terry reel does these across the
countries many many therapists in many
countries do I mean in many cities do
this
we're coming in for 48 hours for a
Friday night and all day Saturday and we
all agree at the end of that Saturday
whether we're staying together or not
we're calling it
like do we have what it takes or do we
have the investment to work on this
thing and if we do here's the behaviors
are going to change immediately and
here's what we're going to work for
together or I'm not into that
I don't want to work on that
and then cool we make an agreement at
five o'clock on Saturday or noon on
Sunday we shake hands and then we go to
mediation we call it there's a lot of
therapists that do that kind of program
I think you that's where y'all are at
I'd agree
so I'd make the call and remember this
behavior is a language if he doesn't
show up he has told you everything you
need to know
if he says I'm not going some stupid
marriage counselor to list I don't hear
none of that you're not going nowhere
quit whining it he's told you everything
you need to know he's not invested in
the future of this relationship
he is leaving by absence
yeah
is that fair
guy just threw a lot at you what are you
feeling
um it makes me nervous to like kind of
bring the idea up but I like the idea
let me say this Renee the idea is out
I promise he's not sitting with his
buddies right now being like man my wife
is the best my marriage is amazing
yeah he knows it's falling apart too
or it's gone
yeah and
sometimes it just takes somebody to say
I'm willing to rebuild if you are
and that that doesn't mean great there's
still a lot of construction has to be
done and a lot of remodeling and a lot
of excavation has to be done but
if you both say you're in you're in just
take somebody to say it out loud
if he came back if y'all went to a
counseling session he said oh my gosh
I'm I'm sorry I've done this all
sideways I'm willing to do it to be
different would you would I give you
peace would you be like awesome my man
or are you done with him
as he said things he says he said things
that you can't come back from I'm not
judging either way I just want to know
like I I think I could be
time to kind of trust that that's
not gonna just
be the same thing that's fair very good
very cool and if he wants to call in
have him call in I'd love to hear his
side of the uh of this story or if you
want to call in together I'd love to
hear that that side too
but yeah this is you've heard me say
this a million times and I'll probably
say a million more before the show's
over
um this is a moment when you gotta turn
the lights on turn the music off and say
okay this is this is the state of our
marriage you talk to me this way and I
will not have that anymore you think I'm
the most annoying this and that and this
and that from these behaviors I we gotta
solve this thing
you don't like being the dad of a young
daughter I I don't like being in a house
where people are screaming we're
teaching our daughters what love looks
like all those things have to be said
and you'll also have to recognize we us
too we don't have the tools in our tool
kits to solve this moving forward
because we would have done that by now
we got to go sit with a professional
I've made an appointment
if you're in it's on Friday
will you join me I hope you will and
that's how this goes man
and he can say no I'm out
oh and you probably need to see that
counselor anyway because there's going
to be somebody that walks alongside you
through whatever comes next
but all said and done you're not crazy
for not wanting to be around somebody
that swears and curses at you and calls
you stupid
and he's probably not crazy for getting
frustrated at whatever
the question is
non can we go back to the way things
were the way things were over
are we both in to building something
completely new
My Hope Is y'all choose yes
but if it's too far gone it's too far
gone be honest be bold be a person of
integrity
as you make your next steps